would you rather give your past self
advice or ask your future self a
question
that's a that's a deep one
ask my future self a question
i guess that that
i only get to do one those are both very
like they feel like those are both
really positive things
um
i'm gonna go with ask my future self a
question just because
i feel like
luckily
i i have the sort of personality in
which i'm always trying to
[Music]
figure things out and come up with sort
of like new and novel approaches uh
to any sort of like problem either
creatively or from a career perspective
and i would like to imagine that that
only gets like
better with age
and i would hope that future me
would have a lot of sort of insight
now
because i guess the other problem is is
that
with that scenario is does young you
listen to you anyway
right because that's
i feel again
at least myself and a lot of people i
think that you are a lot more headstrong
um when you haven't
had as much experience and you haven't
failed in whatever
crazy ways that you failed
right
you think everything
that you're going to do is the correct
answer
um
and so i think that it's it's a little
hard to shake yourself out of that until
you've actually had that experience you
go like oh that really did not work
um
but yeah i imagine that like young me
probably would have been a little
hubristic
and uh would not necessarily take old
me's advice
what would be the question that you
would ask your future self
the question i would ask my future self
yeah dear logan
i have a question
i
uh
like a thousand percent legitimately i
would ask
what
what steps do i need to take now
to ensure
that i'm
holistically happiest in the future
um
i think a thing that a lot of
entertainment people struggle with or
again maybe not a lot of it or maybe
it's just me um
but i think that like at least for me
personally it's the sort of idea of like
uh
again of chasing something that makes
you like feel fulfilled right it's very
easy to be like okay
i've never
i've never had a movie made okay i had a
movie made but it wasn't a big enough
movie how do i get a bigger movie made
okay but it didn't star these it's very
easy to get into that mindset
and i think that
it's really important
even though it's hard
to kind of try to take a step back and
go okay
but like but life still keeps going on
you need to like
try to like focus on like what makes you
happy
in this moment what makes you feel
fulfilled in this moment
um
and not get too caught up
in in the in the chasing of goals i do
like obviously goals are extremely
important you're never going to
reach
um
whatever uh sort of
you're never going to reach the sort of
like fulfillment that like you want like
if you're not setting goals for yourself
and you're not taking these steps to
actually achieve things but i think that
it's very easy to make that solely the
focus and when that's solely the focus
there's a lot that you're missing that's
going on all around you
like uh we were talking about like
originally this sort of idea of like
okay does it look exactly like again
like what i thought of when i was a
child my life
yes or no is one question but is what it
is still really great
you know
um
if you're looking to poke holes in
something you can always poke
holes
like
i'm sure that the like
the richest most successful people on
planet earth have
all the same problems that like
like everyone has and the same sort of
like
the same sort of regrets and the same
sort of like lack of you know whatever
they feel like they're missing
um
it's important to try to not
focus on that
so bring it back around i think that
that's
what i would be
most interested in what strategies
future me
has come up with
to again to effectively like live in the
moment and not get caught up in all the
what-ifs
i think it's great that you're talking
about uh chasing like this these goals
because i think that's so easy to do
whether it's an indie film or if you on
a higher budgeted film because you know
there's a lot of hoopla when a trailer
comes out and then you're reading
comments and hopefully they're positive
and then if the film screen somewhere
okay but some of that stuff is so
short-lived
and then it's on to the next project for
so many people either whether they're
working on it or whether they're going
to see it and so a lot of that is just
like this it's like the evolution of a
movie it's like a you know like a circle
and and some of that
what seems satisfying is so short-lived
so you're always kind of chasing that
where
people are tweeting about it wow this is
so cool or it could be a crowdfunding
campaign or whatever and then it dies
out and then you've got to go on to a
new thing so i think it's really easy to
to fall prey to that
i think that it's
i think that it's important it's
probably more important now than ever
because i think that um
in these sort of like uh social media
validation world
um
that we all live in
it it feels like if you're not doing
something to get that sort of like that
validation and that dopamine like hit
that you like
that you're not
that you're not on the like you're not
on the right path or you're not like
doing what needs to be done and those
things are just entirely different like
regardless of whether or not
like
um
regardless of whether or not you have
something to like showcase in a moment
it doesn't
it shouldn't be about that and i think
that again that's a thing that also
lends itself to feeling like oh well i
should be chasing
this and
there's reasons that that is important
but it's not holistically the most
important thing
um
usually the most important things are
things that you're not like you know
able to talk about or showcase or draw
attention to
right like when you actually like sit
down to do the work
like nobody's giving you attention for
that nobody's like uh
nobody's validating for you for that you
have to validate yourself
um
so yeah i do feel like
more so than i i think it's always been
uh
an issue to be aware of
but i feel like more so than ever
it's something to be like cognizant of
to not get caught up too much
in that and sort of lose the forest for
the trees i guess